僕よく動画編集をするんですけれども～
え～ど、うるさっ
え、もうホントどっから鳴ってんだろ。ヤバいよね音が。
汚ねぇな…。あっつ！ホントに。マジでこれちょっとさぁ、皆に伝えたいんだよね。
動画編集ってね、パソコンにすごい負荷をかけるんですよ
画像編集とかインターネットとか、なんか動画見たりそういうのじゃなくて
動画編集っていう作業って、内容によってはなんですけども
パソコンンに一番負荷を与える作業なのかなと思っております
この今ゴリゴリのめちゃくちゃ
難しい編集してるんですけども、その編集中
パソコンどうなってるかというと
え、はっ　持てないんだけど熱くて
聞こえますか音が
(ｺﾞｫｫｫｫ…）
この風量よ。この音、これを感じてほしいです僕は
いや、ほんっとに熱いんすよ
3カメとかで使って編集してるとホントにパソコンが熱くて
もうどうかしちゃうじゃねーかぐらい熱くなっちゃうんですけども
これ一応Macから出てる最強のパソコンです
そのパソコンをもってしてもここだけ熱くなる
まぁこれだけ熱いとこのパソコンの上に卵を置いたら目玉焼きが作れるんじゃないかと思いまして
今日は処理しすぎてオーバーヒートしているパソコンで卵焼きが
作れるかどうかを検証していきたいと思います
結構画期的だと思いますよ
これが出来るようになれば動画編集しながら卵焼きが食べれるんで
わぁ絶対いけると思うんだよね
はい、と言うわけで早速史上最強のパソコンで
卵焼き作っていこうと思います
ちょっと流石にねこのパソコン壊すわけに行かないので
卵を置けるようにアルミホイルを乗せましょう
うわぁヤバいヤバい　もダメだダメだ
凄いよほら、もう、ヤバい　ほらヤバい
ちょっと予想以上に熱風が強いのでガムテープで抑え込みます
てかこれ抑え込んでいいのかな
よし、はい、出来ました！
この上に卵を乗せていこうと思います
いや卵焼き出来る温度なんだよ！
行きますっ！
（ｺﾝｯ）
（ﾊﾟｶｯ）
(ﾄﾛ~）
(ﾋｭﾝｯ）
ｱｧｯ　（ﾍﾟﾛｯ）
よしおっけおっけ
いい感じに乗ってますねばっちりです
本来パソコンのある場所に食品とかって置いちゃダメなので
結構今シビアな状況に置かれてます
タブーだよ　俺禁忌に触れてるからね今
個人的にスクランブルエッグが良いので
スクランブルエッグにしよっと
はいというわけでこっからなんですけれども
より熱量を上げるためには僕がもっと激しい編集をすればいいんで
もうちょい動画の編集頑張って
パソコンに負荷をかけて熱暴走を悪化させていきたいと思います
めちゃくちゃパソコンが苦しむ編集してやっかんな！
どうしちゃった！？
パソコンが…なんか音が小さくなっちゃった
てかこれ多分、多分卵が多すぎるんだな。
もっと薄くしないと卵焼きは出来ねぇからちょっと吸いますわ
ｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞ…
（ｺﾞｸｯ）
おお…(おいしくもないなぁ)
プラシーボ（？）
ちょっと薄めてみたんで
これだと多分もっと作りやすい気がします
よし、編集頑張ろっ！
ひっくり返るのだけはダメだよ！ホント
うわぁでもすげぇあちぃな
待って、引くレベルで熱いんだけど　ちょっと待った
パソコンが悲鳴を上げてる気がする
いやでもなんかもうちょい
頑張ってくれれば行ける気がするんだよな。ちょっと頑張りましょう！
あ、あっつ！マジで熱い！
あっ消えちゃった！
なんかパソコンがおかしくなって来た…
あっつ、もうホント
触れないレベルで熱いっすわ今
もう一歩だ、頑張ってくれっ！
あっもうヤバい！
まだダメっすよねぇ…
(ﾌﾞｽｩ）
あっ待って！ヤバ待って
穴開いちゃった穴開いちゃった
待って穴開いちゃった！
待った×５
はいとういうわけで少し作戦変更です
Mac Proが熱いというかこの
Mac Proの周りのこの壁
鉄の部分が熱いということが気付いたので
これ多分ねパソコンというより
直でここに置いた方が絶対
卵焼きが出来ると思うんですよね
ここなら卵焼きが出来るかなと思いました
ちょっとこのまま頑張っていきたいと思います
今更に編集して超熱くしてあるんで
この温度なら正直行ける気がします
さぁどうだ！固まれっ！
えー若干白くなって
ちょっと行けると思ったんですけどね
ちょっともう一回温めるんですけど
次はちょっと直に置いてみましょう
今までで一番熱いぞっ！
今までで一番熱い！
これで無理だったらもう諦めますわ
行きますっ！
ﾊｲｯ
どーだっ！どう？
結構ビビるくらいゴリッゴリに熱いんですけど
（ﾍﾟﾁﾍﾟﾁ）
ゴメン無理っ！
ｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｯ
終わり
生の味だなぁ
はじめのためにもチャンネル登録やって上げてくれよな！